okay so I'm answering some more of your
questions from Instagram the first one
is from Rob and it says because of the
nature of science where one needs to
look for funding as opposed to having a
salary like other business you're often
competing against other people and
institutions for research money as a
result you need to have a proactive and
sometimes an aggressive approach to
survive and science my question is would
you agree with that and if so do you
think anyone can succeed in science
especially a person with a generally
more reserved nature so this is pretty
much true that's being a scientist and
being in academia nowadays is not just
about the science it's about a lot of
other things it's about how you pitch
for grant money it's how you communicate
with other researchers it's really quite
similar to other businesses in that
sense that there is a lot of competition
and you sort of can't survive as a
scientist just on your own you need to
be working in groups with other people
so do I agree with that I think it's
good and bad it's good that I think
there's a more collaborative nature to
work because the kind of physics that
we're trying to do requires that I
believe and there's definitely downsides
into the fact that we like what I said
your science can't really speak for
itself you have to speak for your
science so it's just there are people
who are excellent physicists but they
won't succeed in the academic
environment because of the way it's set
up because it favours I think people
that are good at networking I'm good at
socializing do I think someone could
succeed if they're more reserved like I
said
if they don't try to make those
connections with other people then no
but you can be reserved and still be
good at talking to people you don't need
to be especially bubbly or something
like that you just need to be smart at
talking to other people staying in touch
with other people and recognizing when
someone might have interesting work that
they might be interested in what you do
and then you can set up some kind of
collaboration so you can be reserved but
you still have to be on your toes in
terms of socializing with others another
question from a Rob if you were suddenly
appointed the global science president
and could change anything you wish to
about the current system on a whim would
you or would you leave it as it is
there's definitely things I don't like
about the current science system I guess
if I had this power I would do one thing
and that was to increase funding and
science because I think that alone would
probably make a big difference to these
feelings of competitiveness and business
mindset that we feel it's because
science is in general really poorly
funded and it means that it's quite
cutthroat in some sense there's a lot of
people that want to be in the space and
not many jobs can actually be supported
and the other thing I would do was be to
put a focus on like teaching or
education based jobs in academia so what
I mean is that at the moment a lot of
people are employed in the academic or
university system to do research and
then teaching is kind of this obligation
added on to that we're sort of feels
like that person isn't really interested
in teaching or doesn't want to be doing
that as just this obligation they have
to do to get their research money and as
a result I have had some really poor
lecturers over the year
there's people that you could almost
tell they didn't want to be lecturing
these courses at university they just
wanted to throw some notes at us and get
back to doing their research and I think
there should be roles for both kinds of
people I think maybe those people should
be allowed to spend more time on
research if that research is really good
and I think there should be some roles
for people who are actually passionate
about educating university students and
a subject may be doing a little bit of
research but actually being recognized
as being a primarily education position
I think that would really increase the
quality of teaching that goes on in
universities which i think is the most
beautiful physics phenomena probably
know this theorem and understanding
physical phenomena by looking for
symmetries what is your favorite form of
energy without any justification
gravitational potential energy which is
your preferred theory loop quantum
gravity or string theory well hopefully
these are two sides of the same coin is
there any difference between studying
applied physics and physics well I guess
yes some uni's do offer the applied
physics option and I guess it's just a
more broad it's probably more like an
engineering degree in the sense that
what you're studying is probably more
based around the physics ideas that are
useful in industry like most of physics
is useful in industry but if you're
doing applied physics you might be using
simpler maths
maybe a bit more of a simple physics you
probably don't need to understand some
of the complexities of space-time or
something like that
and what we were learning is probably
for someone who has goals to go and work
in industry straight after they
down there studies which is still a
great thing to do but it's probably not
geared towards the academic research
kind of physics any book or other
resources to study essential physics for
everyone other resources I would really
recommend Veritas Ian's channel here on
YouTube even with like a physics degree
I still learn things from his videos all
the time and he covers really quite in
quite an in-depth way actually
interesting concepts in physics in terms
of books for everyone I know some of the
first popular science physics books I
read that gave me sort of a broad
understanding of what's going on in the
field were books by Markus Qian looks
like we need to talk about Kelvin so
that's something I remember enjoying I
probably recommend did you fail a
subject if yes how did you manage to
succeed I never failed a subject at
university the lowest grade I ever got
in a course an undergrad was a B which
is like around 75 percent at the time I
was distraught by that grade and in
hindsight I probably had way too high
expectations and what failure actually
was and I think the reason I did was
because the people I surrounded myself
with my friends and the people I studied
with also had really high expectations
and they were all aiming to get always
above like 90% and so I probably say if
you failed a course or you feel like
you're doing worse than you Carol then
you want to probably change the people
that you surround yourself with because
it can make a huge difference if you're
studying alone and not doing well try to
find some people to study with and if
you've been studying with people that
are maybe bringing you down because they
don't have the same ambitions as you and
they're not aiming for the same grades
you are then don't do group projects
with them
try to get the people that are aiming
for over 90% and try to work with them
it kind of changes your whole mindset
and your work ethic and everything so
that's probably one of the best things
you can do did you even ask do I really
want to be a physicist when things got
tough if so what kept you motivated this
is something that I've not only asked
myself in the past but I always ask
myself
still I think physics is really hard and
often what you're working towards can
always seem really far away and that can
leave you feeling like you're not good
enough or that I don't know that that
it's not worth it I think in a sense
there's not much instant gratification
and physics so to stay motivated what I
sort of think about is why I'm doing
physics in the first place and often I
might come across like a YouTube video
or something that reminds me and it's
the idea that physics is tackling
fundamental questions and I feel like to
work in physics and to work on expanding
human knowledge is one of the nicest
things you can do because you're not
just working you're contributing in a
fundamental way to like the history of
human life I sort of see it in that way
that if I was to leave physics and do
some other job maybe that I would
consider mundane that's just for money
or that I might be good at but I don't
see any sort of fundamental purpose
behind I feel like I wouldn't be
fulfilled and that I'd want to work on
something as exciting and interesting as
physics I really want to study physics
and change to a stem career but I also
feel quite ridiculous because I'm 41 a
law graduate from Brazil married and a
parent of a child do you think it's too
late for me I've had a few variations on
this question before and it's really
hard for me to
say I'm generally quite optimistic and
the idea that you can study physics at
any age and any background and that you
should try and do what you're passionate
about
having said that physics is hard and if
you're coming from a different
background to other people whether
that's you haven't studied physics for
ages or you've got a busy life elsewhere
you're just going to make it harder for
yourself so I'd always recommend doing
what you want to do but you're going to
have to realise that it may be harder
for you and you should probably think
about what you want to get out of doing
a physics degree so a lot of people go
into a physics degree thinking that
they're going to win a Nobel Prize go
into academia be a professor for the
rest of their life and sure some people
do but lots don't and you can go and
work in industry you can go work and
teaching there's lots of other things
you can do but you might not be living
up to your expectations of where
studying physics would take you so if
you're going back to study physics late
in life you should probably think about
why you actually want to do that what
career you see yourself ending up on so
if you want to do it because you want to
go into the uni system become a
professor and do your own independent
research know that that's probably
you're really quite a long road much
more than the three or four year
undergrad degree if you just want to do
the degree for interest and then maybe
switching to a slightly more stem career
and industry or something else sure
that's fine but just be I guess
realistic with your expectations for
after doing the degree I don't think
it's too late to do the physics degree
at any age I know people have done a
really quite late in life I studied with
them and they were great but you just
realized that the degree might be fine
but what are you going to do
that some of my other questions here are
things like explain quantum entanglement
and detail that's something I'd love to
try and do but it's probably a bit too
ambitious for this Q&A so I'm sorry if I
haven't answered your questions from
Instagram but try and type of reply um
and I really do appreciate the amount of
comments I got so thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time